we went to Nashville and we did this Con
and there was this huge tornado they
made us all go down the entire con hotel
to the were you there for what I said to
the parking structure and like it was
serious like Jens and AEL and me and Tom
and Jared we all went down to the
parking structure with all these fans
with all these people in the hotel were
you at all thinking were you thinking oh
you know I've got these two boys and my
wife at home um did that that occur to
you at all do you ever think of that
stuff I literally got a in the face from
Kim who works with us we get back there
the lert goes off and Kim was like okay
we all have to go down to the parking
garage third level uh there's a tornado
coming we all need to go and I turned
around and I go well I don't need to go
because I was thinking I'm G to walk
back two blocks of the hotel right and
she looks at me and she goes do you
really want your wife to hear that
you're the one person that leaves and
dies and leaves your wife and two kids
and I was like let's go down to the
parking garage